bueno lo que se puede lograr es que se
pueda implementar realmente y de menor a
mayor escala es decir municipal
departamental y nacional el programa
nacional integral de sustitución de
cultivos ilícitos que los campesinos
cultivadores de coca puedan encontrar
finalmente un camino claro eficiente y
sostenible en la sustitución de cultivos
ilícitos es decir que se les cumpla
según la oficina de las naciones unidas
contra la droga y el delito en el año
2020 norte de santander fue el
departamento con las cifras más altas en
el país registrando 40 mil 64 hectáreas
definitivo entonces empezar con esta
cumbre en este departamento sin duda
alguna es significativo y de gran
relevancia
bueno y teniendo en cuenta el negocio
que representa la coca la pasta de coca
y el contexto de violencia que vive en
estos territorios qué medidas de
seguridad tendría que tomar el gobierno
previo exigirle a los campesinos que
cambien sus cultivos
la sustitución voluntaria de cultivos
para también por las garantías el
gobierno debe garantizar que se cumpla
del pacto y que no se cumplió sin
embargo el gobierno por ejemplo tiene la
garantía del título de la propiedad sólo
se formalizarán los predios de
cultivadores que estén libres de
cultivos de uso ilícito y de resiembras
y ese es un tema fundamental para los
campesinos la propiedad de la tierra
esto no quiere decir que los que no
cultivan coca no se vayan a vivir a
beneficiar del programa porque su
alcance y sus medidas están pensadas en
beneficio de la comunidad también es
necesario resaltar el diálogo que se
debe crear y de manera urgente si todo
el gobierno y las estructuras armadas
ilegales están sustitución debe pasar
por el des escalamiento de la violencia
pero mencionar eso implica también
mencionar otra arista de las zonas
fronterizas el restablecimiento
diplomático con venezuela el trabajo
conjunto que se debe hacer para mitigar
para minimizar para reducir y para los
riesgos con las vulneraciones de los
derechos humanos que diariamente ocurren
en catatumbo y en todas las zonas
fronterizas del país
bueno y qué tan lejos estaría colombia
de legalizar la hoja de coca este
escenario es factible o la lucha
antidrogas a nivel mundial podría hacer
lo imposible
bueno ese es un tema entre comillas
prematuro sin embargo ya se están dando
algunas discusiones a nivel mundial y se
está planteando algunos o sus
alternativos ilícitos y legítimos a
nivel nacional sin embargo es un tema
transversal y desde varios ministerios
están dando estos debates debemos
esperar
y estar atentos estar atentos a las
directrices de ejecutivos del link de
activo bueno hoy al hablar de
sustitución hay que tener en cuenta qué
opciones cuáles serían las opciones de
cultivos que podrían implementar los
campesinos si dejan de cultivar hoja de
coca
bueno la opción para la sustitución de
cultivos es sin duda que se les cumpla a
los campesinos hay que cumplirles eso
que se les prometió que se les han
cumplido entonces en ese sentido la
opción para la sustitución de cultivos
ilícitos es que se les cumpla el plan
nacional integral de sustitución de
cultivos ilícitos